welcome to this video clearing Dorrit
from Germany the turf teammate of mine
so let's see what what we get always a
bit tricky to play play teammates you
know each other really well let's see
I'm playing a g6 type of Salim looking
two together version of the maroc see
bind but with some some traits already
am already done III yeah maybe he's
going for before him yeah yeah okay
let's retreat the queen Knight c3 could
be interesting I can maybe take it yeah
he's he's waiting for me to play Knight
f6 so that after after that he wants to
go I wonder
I wonder if I'm he wants to you wait for
Knight f6 to play Knight c3 is there
some way to use that I can I can can try
that mmm yeah there is not know rejected
here no Knight c3 at least would be
hanging cap but still Knight f6 93's are
perfectly okay what the body moves like
is six is this crazy e 6 97 it's very
uncommon to do that but it cannot so
easily develop now and the night on yeah
this is what I have what I expected
let's grab now and then I thought night
before maybe alrighty 485 establishing
this piece okay let's at least at least
an interesting position it's not very
standard with the knight on d4 yeah
probably Queen III or queen d 3 yeah
maybe to get an ID be five I wanted to
to do this anyway get this Knight to c6
hmm now maybe maybe to know maybe if
I've was was a more precise ok that's a
pin son and d6 hangsen so neither three
I can take with check that's very
necessary ok and it's not so easy to
unpin that oh it's not trying to use it
really yeah maybe queen takes this looks
better than get to get into another
another pin
oh that's not too bad with the night
jaan on d4 I wonder about before with
you should do before maybe okay that's
that's interesting that's interesting if
I he might get the night to d5 but okay
the knight on d4 is not not especially
bad so and i have i have some some porn
breaks to undermine the knight on d5 if
it arrives on d5
rook c8 and B fires another yeah okay he
probably will play a form attack attack
my center no now that's very safe not
bad ok let's get this exchanged and what
now let's activate here if he can try
rook to d5 through p5 this this kind of
idea maybe hmm maybe my idea was to get
the look on the fourth-ranked and then
play with a for this is some probably
not such not really possible okay but it
does not doesn't look does not look too
critical I'm glad that he's spending
some some time here get rid of one week
porn
okay yeah okay thats that leads to
shower play if he takes with the f porn
to get in now it doesn't would have been
interesting I get the porn means oh okay
this was the idea all along to have a
four okay he's blocking that yeah
probably a good decision Joe very
difficult to make any progress here
especially for black try to get some
trades going the rukon b5 is an active
piece so trying to trade it I wonder
okay
I'm trying to try to play actively it's
it's a bit risky maybe check if i go
here oh yeah he will take with the pawn
and then take be 6 mm that's not really
great okay okay it says some way to to
give it up here look on the second and
that's very risky and I'm down on time
but I know that isn't she so quick so
this is probably this is risky but
interesting this pawn
threatening check and e2 needs to do do
something about it yeah that's it's very
draw much still because of my activity
check I've got two pesos check I'm
warning check check I know he cannot
check from from behind check check yeah
this was white forfeits all times well
the tough endgame which probably should
be drawn at term while always possible
to to do some kind of some kind of
tricks and it was very risky my play him
I think this is really this should end
in a draw but came it's this was
interesting so ya know this Andrew KJ
this was the most active way to play
entering here but he can he can just he
took which is probably not bad but can
also just cover the entry squares this
is very safe I probably just need to
play route b8 back end so it's nothing
happening ok here we we have a sharp
position I went to see to to control c5
this one yeah edit it still should be a
draw and here if it's I don't know that
this is risky I mean again I can instead
of e3 I can probably just stay put like
like this white cannot really make any
any big headway
here hmm yeah maybe there's some way for
him to play for when the computer gives
right about the power advantage this
move hmm it's not so easy to to make a
move here something like that now you
might take and now wins an important
tempo on this with the idea c5 that's a
bit tricky yeah I played played it in a
very risky fashion yeah here you cannot
expect any any precision with this kind
of time computer wants to go here yeah
intending this and after look-see for
King you through your son match check
now eh it's just the drawer really a
check check yeah I tricked him into this
position and now it's it's a problem
those two pawns are simply very
dangerous because they're fart want the
computer is giving it as a win already
minus four so I'm promoting yeah I
couldn't really be sure about that but
it looks very dangerous those pawns are
simply more dangerous in the rook
endgames it's often more about quality
than quantity so here White is losing
all right thanks for watching